to mark the onset of the festive season
a miniature town made up of 2,000
delectable buildings has been unveiled
in Bergen Bergen is Norway's
second-biggest city but it boasts the
largest gingerbread town in the world
all this was made by Kirstie Broxton
she's the architect of the sugary
settlement
when you go around looking we want the
audience to dream themselves into for
instance that's they can dream that
they're sitting in at the French cafe or
they can dream that they are sitting in
a poor can go into the merry-go-round
and yeah they can we want to give them
the experience of escaping from the
reality and into a into a fantasy land
fantasy land local residents pitched in
to help build gingerbread city inner
garden schools families and local
societies all got involved a total of
10,000 volunteers contributed to the
tiny town including members of bargains
coastal culture center
for morons drama baking together has
become a tradition there I enjoyed this
social with people you make something
nice for Christmas the gingerbread
artists drew inspiration from the old
buildings around the coastal Culture
Centre they used to store dried cod fish
now they house museums or they function
as tool sheds combine this with a pinch
of creativity and you get some great
results Kirstie Broxton was getting
gingerbread creations right up to the
very last minute so improvisation was
key you never know what you get so then
you maybe have to change the landscape a
bit we if we get a lot of Eiffel Towers
for instance we I tried to make Paris a
small Paris part and then we get the
maybe the Kremlin Cathedral and then I
have to make space for that rock star
and her team of 30 worked for about a
month to transform the 400 square meters
of a former swimming pool into a hilly
winter wonderland
Steiner Kristofferson began the festive
tradition 26 years ago back then it was
more of a gingerbread Hamlet the idea
came in 1991 when I was a marketing
director of shopping center we had an
exhibition area where we wanted to do
something for children and then we got
the idea of making the gingerbread city
since then bergen's gingerbread town has
morphed into a major tourist attraction
some 100,000 visitors flocked to see it
each year
some of them even join in to help build
the town there are five hours together
and building all these houses and all
these features who is in a musical for
children and family it's called the
Christmas the magic of Christmas
we made a free bomb it's the little
train that goes up and down the hills in
Bergen picking up the kids build a
different themed house each year this
year's theme was Halloween the
architecture of the miniature town is
certainly diverse the train chugging
along a tiny track leads from buildings
in the Norwegian style to the Eiffel
Tower and maybe a short stop at London's
iconic Big Ben berrigan's delectable
gingerbread city will be on display
throughout the Christmas season until
December 31st